hi this is presh talwalkar
let's play the mathematical game of spin
until you lose
you have a wheel with three values of
end one dollar and two dollars
you spin the wheel until it lands on one
of the values
if it lands on one or two dollars you
bank that amount of money
in this case one dollar and then you
spin the wheel again
if you end up on two dollars on your
next spin
you get to add that amount to your bank
so now we have a total of three dollars
in the bank and we keep spinning the
wheel
if we land on the value of end
that means the game is over and we cash
out whatever value we banked
so in this game we've won three dollars
the puzzle for you
is if you play this game
how much do you expect to win on average
some of the games you're going to end up
you know finishing on end right away
other games you may continue to keep
spinning and win more and more
the puzzle to you is how much money do
you win on average
if you solve that problem also give the
problem of the general case a try
imagine a wheel
that has values that go up from one
dollar all the way up to n dollars
each space on the wheel is equally
likely to be landed on when you spin the
wheel
the same rules apply
you keep spinning the wheel and banking
money until you land on the value of end
in which case you cash out the banked
amount
how much money do you win in the general
case
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
if you try and solve this by explicitly
calculating how many ways you can win
one dollar two dollars and so on it's
going to be an infinite series that's
very difficult to solve
so there's a
trick let's imagine we have a variable x
which denotes the average winnings of
our gameplay
we can split up x into the three
different outcomes for the first turn
this is known as the law of total
expectation
so we can either consider x as landing
on end on the first term we can consider
landing on one dollar on the first term
or we can consider landing on two
dollars on the first term
each of these are equally likely
now if we land on end then on the first
turn there's a one-third chance that
we're going to end up with zero dollars
we simply end the game
what happens if we land on one dollar on
our first turn
in that case
we're going to get one dollar in our
bank and essentially we start the game
exactly over because once you banked one
dollars
you it's like you started the game from
scratch you're going to expect going
forward a total value of x dollars
so if you land on one on your first turn
then you're going to expect one dollar
more than x
so there's a one-third chance you'll end
up
getting x plus one dollars
similarly if you land on two dollars on
your first turn
it's as if the game has started over
except you have an extra two dollars
so your expectation in this case will be
that you're going to expect to make two
dollars more than x
so we combine this in the expectation we
have an expression for x
we can now simplify this
i'm going to group out the one-third
term i'm going to have 2x and then we
have the sum of the dollar values of 0 1
and 2.
we end up solving that x is equal to 3
and this is interesting our average
value is equal to the sum of one and two
dollars which are the values on the
wheel
is this true for the general case let's
find out and prove that it actually is
true for the general case
so if we have a wheel that goes from one
dollar all the way up by one dollar
increments to n dollars
we denote x as our average winnings
and then we're going to split up x into
all the different values that we land on
the first turn
these are all equally likely
and it's going to give us an expectation
based on what we land on for the first
turn
if we land on n dollars remember we're
going to expect n dollars more than x so
we now have this interesting expression
and the numbers on the right go from 0 1
all the way up to n
so these are the number this is equal to
the sum of the numbers from 1 to n which
is a familiar formula of n times n plus
one over two
we simplify this expression and we find
out
that the amount that you expect to win
is equal to n times n plus one over two
which is the sum of all the values on
the wheel
so it's a kind of interesting result
that this probability game you end up
with the sum of the numbers from 1 to n
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
provided links in the video description